質問コーナーです
ハイお待たせしました、質問コーナーでございます
すみませんちょっと時間がかかりました
質問・リクエスト
たくさんいただきました
今回もありがとうございます
出来ればたくさん答えたいのですけど も
なかなかそういうわけにもいかないので
まぁ、大量のコメントを読むのに時間がかかったり
いろいろ時間がかかるのですよ
僕の質問コーナーは
またいつかやろうと思うので
もし今回も答えてもらえなかったなていう人は
また次回是非コメントお待ちしております
なんか、質問というよりリクエストの方が多いんだよね
ま、適当に行きます適当に
ではいこう
キャー
正直この新しい家にしてから
前の部屋より全然広いんですよ
なので
正直すごい寂しいです
やっぱり、部屋が広いと寂しく感じるんだよね
キリッ
キラッ
帰れぇ!
いつも自分の道を行くはじめさんに勇気をもらってます!
大学卒業後は多分
進学しようかな...
と、今のところ思っております
ちょっと映像系学びたいと思ってて
帰れぇ!
あの、この前注意してからまだ一人も来てません
ありがとうございます
やっぱりみんな話すとわかる人なんだよね
俺ん家来るなよ
いやいや、こっちがなんなんですか?
だから、なんなんですか?
いや、なんなんですよ
にんにん
あ、こわっ
ちょっと待って怖い
にんにん
うわー
..............................................................................................
...帰れぇ!
オチョチョチョチョチョネ
オチョネネ
ホニョニョ
ムヌアプチュチュピチュ
ホチュア
マチュブークチュバチェペチェブー
アムールーーーーーー
ホニュ...
今、出来てたっしょ?
バカでしょ自分でぶつけるもんじゃないでしょこれは
いきまーす
痛ぁー
うおぉおい
エヘエヘエヘエヘエヘ...
バカにしてるのか?
やるわけないか...
なんでさせた?
大好きです!
あれでしょ、モンハンの緊急回避ってこの
ブワァーて跳ぶやつでしょ
マジか...
なんか、質問というよりリクエストコーナーみたいになってるね
まぁいいでしょう
楽しい質問・リクエストありがとうございました
また質問をリクエストするときに
ちゃんと動画を出すので
是非またコメント質問お持ちしております
なんか超ハードだったんだけど今回
じゃあな！
新しいハンマー買った
割とでかいの買いましたからね
空き缶なんてワンパン
危ない…
持てない重すぎて